I it's not that I do not believe that
there is a type of Life there but I
think it's very strange that we're all
considering that it will be a guaranteed
baby at the end of it so the reason why
I consider
a fetus especially in the earlier stages
to be a potential life is because 20 of
all pregnancies end in a miscarriage
anyway but I mean there's also a number
of other things that could happen in
this span of time
um and I mean stillbirths is still one
in 175 as well if you're particularly
unlucky as and removing all variables
though
um so for something to be a life uh that
we find I guess valuable
it makes sense to consider viability and
certainly an embryo is not what do you
mean by viability
it could breathe
if it if it can sustain its own system
by itself okay and that doesn't and that
is not the same as the fact that a
mother needs to feed it and such I guess
though that does get difficult if we
because we're talking here about what
makes a life alive and that's actually a
pretty important legal question later on
where I think about human rights
violations right who gets to have human
rights as a you know as a human person
outside of the worm and if we're saying
that a human is only a human only
deserves the right to life if they're a
conscience conscious or if they are
breathing and supporting their own body
on their own without any help from
anyone that puts in a very difficult
situation people who are lying in comas
I knew you was going to say that it's a
very difficult situation it's not the
same like it's not the same so you're
using all of these analogies it's not
the same okay so what about conjoined
twins
okay so twins there's many illegal cases
on this these are twins that have shared
organs maybe one of them is using the
other one's heart they're fully
dependent they're linked by their bodies
it's a very intimate relationship that
doesn't just go on for nine months it
goes on for the entirety of their lives
and yet the law has been completely
clear if you have a sister that is
sharing your heart and that is using
your heart the law is absolutely clear
you cannot kill them even though they're
dependent on you they can't sustain
themselves they're invading your body in
a very if you're sharing a heart they
would die you'd both die that was I mean
yeah that's a
I mean there are cases like you know
sharing a liver for example so you know
there's a there's a there was born like
that that's how they that's a uh however
that is
the same can you kill one and keep the
other anyway though that doesn't make
sense if one dies both of them Dino I
think he's talking about conjoined twins
no but even if they're conjoined like
how is that even a choice like when you
have like they're still twins yeah you
know what I mean no so if you're even
thinking about abortion by them thinking
about twins you would only think about
that if you're thinking about getting
rid of both of them you couldn't make a
choice of oh I'm gonna get rid of one
and keep the other anyway even no no
someone might do that but is that even
possible it's actually quite common yeah
we know because the department of health
keeps pretty good statistics on abortion
and says why every single abortion is
done
the NHS website if you look it's called
selective reduction or multiple
pregnancy and quite a few abortions each
year are done basically because there
are too many babies and they have to get
rid of some so hold on just based on
what you said because I I actually
understood your when after you made it
um what she's saying is it true like can
you if you've got twins growing in you
and you decide to kill one of them and
can you keep the other twin alive yeah
because I actually don't know if you can
do that yeah it's quite common but then
really it's possible
but really see this is actually this is
things like that that's the reason why I
would kind of understand why science is
really good because that would be
pro-life because
who would really want to make that
decision what kind of person does that
if you have twins you have twins
yeah but then if it's Financial don't
have a baby but some people might have
only planned to have money for one yeah
I mean I mean I'm not saying I'm just
really shocked I didn't know it was
scientifically possible
when they made when they made abortion
it was supposed to be like safe rare
like it wasn't supposed to be like I
just think it's gotten ridiculous to the
point one out of three women are having
them it's birth control how many
abortions can you even have that's
another thing I want to say I can't
remember the exact number but it's
roughly 40 percent of women that have
had abortions about two or more so is
there a cap on it can I'm sorry
damage your body or something like I
mean I'm pretty sure it must definitely
something yeah yeah well and and I've
heard stories of girls that have eight
nine abortions like and that's what I'm
saying like it's not even safe and rare
anymore it's just women making poor
decisions so in the 1980s the average
woman in Romania has eight abortions
well that was the average woman wait in
Romania Romania in the 1980s or maybe
1960s why was there no contraception
there was no contraception okay well
that makes more sense yeah I mean yeah
so they they you know there was no
contraceptions but they could have
abortion well there's very limited that
doesn't make sense or why did they do
that well and I just think all of these
reasons just come to be excuses when
it's just like we can close our legs we
don't have to make children with like
these bad guys
sorry no I agree with you probably it
sounds like a blaming women sometimes
yeah I am a woman but
it's like why can't we start with the
women before we go to the men we always
talk about men's room
but men are legally responsible if they
get a girl pregnant they have to pay
child support So after after we we both
get pregnant that's equally is that
working
wait listen listen if we if we get
pregnant it's equally irresponsible
right I mean I would argue it's more
than women but we'll we'll for that for
the well I mean when you think about I
know okay think about it we got we got
10 choices they have condom no condom we
know when we ovulate we can get on birth
control we can do plan B did you know
that you can do an abortion adoption
like we have all these choices the men
have one did you know that the
um contraception pill was actually
designed for men originally it was okay
but and they take it now but the thing
is I wow there it is so it's there is is
because
I think actually that they just I did
that well you probably know better than
me that it was better for the women to
take it because you know like the the
men didn't want to happen in that study
it was like one or two of them died I
want to say so that was why they had to
cut it because some women died as well
I don't think think it's that common I
think it's more I think the reason is a
bit more common sensical like it I think
it's easier to
um
to lock off one egg than 100 million
sperm
I just think that's the reason why it's
harder to find contraceptive performance
no no they made it work it's just that
men didn't like the side effects effects
of uh birth control
no but it was it was sterilization and
one or two people died in that study so
that's why they were like way worse than
the side effects for women suicidality
is a side effect for women's birth
control when 90 of women are on it I
just don't think it's that common
especially when men commit suicide more
so the women we need to raise our voice
women trying to get into suicide and the
contraception as well women try to con
to commit suicide more but they tend to
be less successful because they don't
pick lethal methods well I think it so
so men are better at suicide than us is
that true that at that point is true but
if we're on societal arguments that is
sort of where my
um interest is so when it comes to
thinking okay so what benefits are there
if we ban abortion well theoretically
that would potentially be more kids that
could be a bonus um the birth rate is
falling in a lot of developed countries
but when I think of what the negatives
are
um it's significantly more in my opinion
for women if you start to take away
these types of Rights they are going to
naturally feel oppressed it's going to
reduce the things that they do they're
going to change the behavior they're
going to be having sex less
relationships less and already gen Z is
having relationships less and sex less
so it might not necessarily maybe
they'll maybe they'll even marry babies
maybe their marriage rates falling as
well well if we ban divorce I think
maybe it would go back up that's a whole
different time
yeah but if I'm honest sorry I'll just
finish my point quickly
um I don't think abortion rate will drop
I think that legal abortions will drop
because obviously they won't be
available which means more women are
going to have medical side effects from
procuring illegal abortion drugs
I think women more women in jail I think
women might think twice before maybe
sleeping with the whole football
I think I think one out of three
abortions is a lot of abortions
I understand and you know I think we
should punish people that get those I
think that should be illegal too you
know that the prosecution rate for all
crime in general is pretty abysmal right
it's just it's it pays to be a criminal
we can we can make the process can I
just say
um an unpopular opinion
um
amongst women
uh but I have heard it time and time
again from Men
which is you know that breakups are
harder for men than it is on women and
the reason is because women
are the ones with the choice so women
choose who they sleep with like we have
more Choice whether so if we say no
unless you're graped
we say no and that's it the men have to
beg and they and take us and where was
and do this and that and we what are the
ones and we're the only ones that no one
were ovulating to you can only get
pregnant like five days a month yeah but
we also know if you're a birth control
or not a lot of women lie about it yeah
yeah yeah they do they do and we also
can he can't make you take a plan B so
we have all these choices so before I
get attacked by women yeah I'm not
saying that I'm not saying that like you
know
do Bell I'm just saying that I've been
told from many men and I was thinking
yeah you're right they're not like
whoever we have slept with women
we unless it's been some you know a
different situation
um in a normal situation we know we're
the ones that have said okay
okay
it's always on the woman
so the woman has the last say
in sex
and we know when we're on we know um
what we're taking we know what we're so
it's like if you're going to have sex
with I mean sorry sex uh if you're gonna
sleep with someone and then you you
uh not on the pill
he's not wearing a condom
you're not on anything and you still
don't go and get the morning after pill
or you don't whatever you and then go oh
I'm pregnant
like damn I think I'm shocked how did
that happen I know I like
I know I'm in this situation
right that's that's what I say it's
because we have all of these choices to
prevent these things like yet we will
still say but men when I bring this up
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible